o pessoal que quer falar andar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um é o meu hoje
trago aqui o vídeo fez tanto pedem de
passes tanto esperam como assustaram com
um amigo 5 a 15 sporting preocupe está
em casa eu mas também eu sou idiota
coisa que vocês podem perceber são
algumas diferenças em mim fisicamente
bem
a primeira delas é óbvia deixe de usar
óculos portanto vocês vão começar a vir
assim sem óculos porque porque agora
usar muitos contatos vocês não têm idéia
das dores de cabeça que eu tinha já com
os óculos do estado enfrenta o abc
receberá que os reflexos de luz está bem
eu sei que eu sou parceiro chinês um
tailandês um coreano começou sua digamos
que eu ainda sou um pouco bonito e
euforia vieram com óculos mas olha é
assim e outra pequena diferença que
vocês também vão ver primeira vez que o
beque está um pouco mais magrinha não é
as meninas que estava em mim portanto a
medida que vocês vão ver agora este
vídeo que vão saindo eu vou ficando mais
magro não estranhei e humanos drogas não
é a única coisa onde eu ando aniston
aqui
esta coisa que esta esta magnífica enfim
só vai conversar todos aprovaram um
pequeno prédio só pra vocês não acharam
estranho agora nem mais é nova então
restrito só vamos ajustar o pior não
esqueçam quero pedir uma ajuda muito
importante mesmo é já começar ou é muito
importante só existe uma lista do top
100 dias do mundo e os djs portugal
estão a participar ou cairemos preciso
muito da nossa ajuda através de votos
portanto façam como vou explicar a
seguir ao cair da sacada no primeiro em
que fazer nem como destaque
preciso que vocês votem neste 5 de junho
sempre às voltas com kevo é segundo gol
dá entre sério tom e 11 em quarto e
diego miranda e em quinto careto é só
seguir essa ordem de votação e clicar em
continue só quando vocês concluir um
voto já sabem fazer lá no instagram faz
um histórico e identifica e eu vou
procurar ok quem votar eu vou procurar e
fica em proveito pessoal conectar um
guichê com o dj que evo portanto votem
muito por fazer e filho com ela ok ok o
vídeo já começou com a ufam vou explicar
porque ok se encomendar uma nova marca e
pratos da upe e uma encomenda e neuri
decidi comprar uma máscara do pne iguais
ou seja do filme e da maldição olha o
que eu falar o que você conhece e imagem
estava não isso é esta e o que chegou à
casa foi isto tá muito poder
mas eu acho que dá para assustar ninguém
que não se assusta com o palhaço pasta
canon que estas coisas dos chineses
sabem que o cheiro a borracha do banco
[Música]
[Aplausos]
antónio boto costa jogada em 2011 é não
fazer nada não faca
[Aplausos]
não tem jogo mas sentiu fisgada e com o
qual o cabeça mexe em jaraguá e
percebido que ele estava mesmo assim a
olha então faça o favor
o convite sbt na casa pode ser o quarto
tento
[Aplausos]
o governo olha daí 4 bilhões no período
normal
o perigo agora não vamos sair mais
[Música]
coisas que não devia me bastante e dava
caixa onde estava muito bem escondido é
que você pode ter falhas criticando a
falta de substância com isso e vão só
agora vamos tentar ajustar o pico um
balão na porta com uma armadilha vamos
ver se resulta eu vi esse vídeo no que
toca a todos vocês que estão no verdy
tokyo usar a aplicação melzer é este
aqui vocês podem ir lá e postarem os
vídeos porque a única coisa que eu
precisei pioneses um bolão precisado e
collor ii resultou em toy funciona
[Música]
[Aplausos]
em 2015 mas também temos aqui um papel
por causa do compromisso civis ea
polícia da casa pedro muito bom por isso
aqui tá muito povo português vamos ter
muito risco tanto por si só vão sair de
casa vendo que toda a confirmação pois
vocês daqui com mais criteriosas estamos
vendo a fiação de rock
ó
op
[Música]
a foto é o de que quando chegou a 61
[Aplausos]
[Música]
alguns têm nada a deus o rio perdeu no
total já foi embora porque não mereço
isaac robin pobre é bom empatar pois é
difícil de precisar matar com isso dois
mandatos
e é só este foi o clima está um amigo 5
espero que vocês tenham gostado sabe
deixei muito líquidos filho podia
encostar no time que também quiserem ver
mais um começo estava um amigo como ele
tem muito em baixo já sabe como gay e
não esqueçam pessoal
votem nos top 100 djs portugal quem vota
em uma lista que você é muito importante
é isso fiquem até apróxima